willkommen zu einer neuen sendung von
viel okaz diesmal mit niki luca toni du
hast ein neues buch geschrieben mit dem
titel die zehn gebote des gesunden
menschenverstandes nikhil erzähl uns
doch mal ganz kurz was ist eigentlich
gesunder menschenverstand
was kann man sich darunter vorstellen
als philosoph geht man ja das weißt du
an solche fragen immer so ein bisschen
methode schrank und dann versucht man
vielleicht mal so ein begriff wie den
gesunden menschenverstand
irgendwie so abzuprüfen mit blick darauf
was kann man darüber sagen was klingt
natürlich das klingt weniger natürlich
und wir sind zwei sachen aufgefallen
nämlich zum einen wenn wir sagen
irgendwie ja das hat mir mein gesunder
menschenverstand aber ich musste erstmal
ganz hart überlegen und wirklich um die
ecke denken das passt irgendwie nicht so
gut zusammen also irgendwie sagen das
ist gesunde menschenverstand sagen ja
eigentlich immer das liegt doch auf der
hand hast und wie also geradezu
offensichtliches scheint ein
charakteristikum zusammen und das andere
ist wenn man dinge auf eine art und
weise formulieren muss die nur experten
verstehen dann ist es auch komisch wenn
man das gesunden menschenverstand
also es muss irgendwie jedem zugänglich
sein das haben wir schon mal zwei
kriterien und was ich dann getan habe in
dem buch war zu analysieren welche
vernunft grundsätze es gibt die diese
beiden kriterien erfüllen also es liegt
irgendwo auf der hand das kann man nicht
wirklich anders sehen und jeder kann das
verstehen was wir dazu sagen und
ausgekommen sind zehn gebote die
hoffentlich ein
guter vorstellen dafür sind wir
denkfehler vermeiden janni gilt jetzt
hast du schon hier angesprochen es gibt
gebote und zwar zehn gibt es mehr gebote
gibt es genau zehn warum gerade zehn du
bist du darauf gekommen es gibt genau
zehn ja aber ich hätte das natürlich
auch so einteilen können wir sieben oder
12 14 es natürlich eine schöne zahl
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen künstlich
das so einzuteilen ist könnte man auch
anders machen aber ich glaube über den
inhalt der gebote können die nicht
wirklich streiten
also das sind wirklich die dinge die wir
beachten müssen wenn wir nachdenken über
sachfragen oder über
handlungsentscheidungen wo man nicht
wirklich eine andere einschätzung
vertreten kann es wäre sehr unvernünftig
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel das erste
gebot ist bringt ordnung in dann denken
also wenn man jetzt also konnten wir
noch ein bisschen anders ist
dazu können wir dann auch noch kommen
vielleicht aber wenn jetzt jemand sagen
würde nie denke lieber unordentlich und
würde man sagen okay was meinst du denn
jetzt vielleicht mit
kreativitätstechniken oder man kommt
vielleicht irgendwie gut auf ideen oder
vielleicht will man ja auch ein
gesprächspartner verunsichern oder wieso
also es kann vielleicht in bestimmten
kontexten vernünftig seien ordentlich zu
denken aber nicht wirklich wenn du
selber nach einer antwort auf eine
offene frage ist wer hat da sollte man
versuchen zunächst mal ordnung zu
schaffen und jetzt was bedeutet das
zunächst mal werde klar über welches
thema überhaupt nachdenkst wir sprechen
jetzt gerade über ein philosophisches
thema bekannten auch über fußball
sprechen oder irgendwelche anderen
tränen das heißt das ist das erste was
wir machen sollen ja dann würde man auch
sagen das ist doch klar oder 90 liegt
auf der hand es ist jedem eingängig
kents erstmal das thema ab im rahmen
dieses themenkomplexes gibt es dann halt
verschiedene fragen auf die man zu
sprechen kommen könnte und es liegt auf
der hand dass man sagt wir klären erst
mal die frage stellen
und wenn wir die fragestellung haben das
hat man welchen möglichen antworten wird
es geben und dann testet man
provisorisch
was würden denn für diese und jede
antwort sprechen und dann sagt man
okay ich habe jetzt eine provisorische
käse und dann gebe ich die gründe die
für diese these sprechen und das ist
eigentlich genau das was wir meinen was
wir professionell betreiben wenn das
video wirft ihm machen was wir meinen
wir sagen wir bringen ordnung in unser
denken hat das ist zum beispiel das
erste gebot und ich würde sagen nichts
von dem was ich gesagt habe ist
irgendeiner weise kontrovers und
dementsprechend liegt auf der hand hier
kann es nachvollziehen das ist einfach
nur diese unsere menschenverstand
janicki jetzt hast du hier geschrieben
der gesunde menschenverstand da stellt
sich die frage gibt es auch so etwas wie
den gesunden menschenverstand was wäre
der woran würde man den zähnen erkennen
können ja dass ich würde sagen ungesund
klingt fast ein bisschen suggestiv man
also gesunder menschenverstand ist ja
irgendwohin feststehende ausdruck also
das geld damit meinen können wir jetzt
klärt aber wenn man sagte mir und
gesunde menschenverstand würde sagen das
würde wahrscheinlich auch jemanden zu
treffen der systematisch diese gebote
des gesunden menschenverstandes verletzt
und sich auch nicht eines besseren
belehren lässt das ist wahrscheinlich da
niemand den gesunden menschenverstand
hat könnte man zum beispiel sagen so was
wie die sophisten in der antike hermann
den aristoteles also er ist nicht so
weit entfernt von den solisten man
sieht's nicht im denken oder zeit
natürlich könnte man so was wie
sophisten sich denken oder harry
frankfurt hat ein buch geschrieben und
bullshit also die bullshit die sich
überhaupt nicht an die unterscheidung
zwischen wahr und falsch halten wäre es
so etwas in dieser art also man würde
einfach gewisse denk gesetze die sich
aufdrängen die auf der hand liegende
systematisch ignorieren aus bestimmten
gründen die vielleicht privatinteressen
bedeuten könnte man sich das so
vorstellen genau das ist
eigentlich die definition von bullshit
nun also der bullshit im sinne von harry
frankfurt würde dann waren bestehen dass
wir sprechen über ein thema und du
möchtest irgendwie also wirklich meine
gene einschätzung erfahren
aber ich möchte ich eigentlich nur
beeindrucken mit der anzahl von
fremdwörtern ich kenne und deswegen
lasse ich dich immer so einfließen mir
geht's gleich darum dass wir in der
sache über einkommen oder das irgendwie
wahrheit finden sondern ich versuchen
anderen zweck zu erreichen
bei politikern das ist zum beispiel
genau sondern die wollen sich irgendwie
den wählerlisten so anbietern und sagen
dass in dinge die gefallen aber es geht
ja gar nicht darum irgendwie so eine
diskussion zu führen also zumindest das
glaube ich in vielen politischen
diskussionen vor allem in
wahlkampfzeiten sind nachweis dass sowas
stattfindet und die sophisten haben es
natürlich ganz genau so gemacht das war
im prinzip eigentlich bezahlte
dienstleistungen wie kann man vor
gericht gut aussehen oder wie kann man
irgendwie leuten denen wir verkaufen und
so weiter und da gelten andere maßstäbe
die man auch systematisch erfassen kann
aber die verletzt sind dann unter
umständen den gesunden menschenverstand
systematisch also da geht es dann eher
darum wie kann man jemanden über treppen
und wir zum eigenen vorteil die person
dazu bringen bestimmte dinge zu glauben
da hat man interesse sind aber das ist
das wäre genau die umkehrung an
ist das gesund das bringt mich zur
letzten frage würdest du sagen dass der
gesunde menschenverstand auch seine
gewisse normativität enthält in moral
philosophischer hinsicht also ist
derjenige oder diejenige die sich an den
gesunden menschenverstand hält
automatisch auch besser in moralischer
hinsicht andere der oder diejenige
besser ich würde sagen du hast eine
höhere chance das zu tun was moralisch
geboten ist weil was moralisch geboten
ist ist ja eine frage über die wir
genauso nachdenken über jede andere
frage auch das heißt in vieler hinsicht
ist es dann auch so kann es strittig
sein
was das richtige ist zu tun und wenn man
daran also die moralische qualität eines
menschen irgendwie festmachen wollte
dann würde ich sagen also dass zumindest
ein notwendige bedingung dafür dass man
dass man also nachhaltig das richtige
tut ja das könnte man sagen das kann man
übrigens sie auch feststellen in
verschiedenen mit button die sehr stark
emotional aufgeheizt sind wenn man zum
beispiel die flüchtlings debatte nimmt
was man feststellen kann es gibt viele
leute die so sehr stark moralischen
motiviert sind und die sagen dann ja es
sind da leute und den muss man noch
helfen und die vernachlässigen
beispielsweise also darauf wieder ruhe
in unserem neuesten buch hingewiesen
über grenzen denken vernachlässigen den
aspekt der kosten den das hat für unsere
gesellschaft und die frage was man
alternativ mit diesem geld das man
aufwenden muss um flüchtlinge zu
integrieren in deutschland tun könnte am
guten bei denen wirklich an
also subsahara afrika beispielsweise
also die leute die zu uns kommen sie die
eigentlich schon gewissermaßen
begünstigt dadurch dass sie überhaupt in
der lage sind trans continental zu
reisen und die ärmsten der armen bleiben
zwölf ländern die dann komplett desolat
sind und die moral würde vielleicht
sagen wenn man so systematisch drüber
nachdenken und versucht denkt wieder zu
vermeiden dass wir zunächst mal den
leuten helfen sollten das ist nur ein
beispiel das zeigt dass man schon ein
bisschen nachdenken muss und denkt
wieder vermeiden sollte den gesunden
menschenverstand walten lassen sollte in
diesen fragen und auch zu moralisch
besseren einschätzung zu kommen
naviki vielen dank für diese auskunft
über den gesunden menschenverstand wir
verabschieden uns bei philo cast und
sehen uns bei einer der nächsten folgen